push it in there bumpkin sharp pudding
yeah I eat a bag of [ __ ] on fire hi hey
welcome to life advice with Seth Rogen
and Chloe grace Moretz James 82 Kendall
asks our neighbors have to make in the
tons of noise even during our exam
season what's the best way to get back
at them put you in their mouth and sharp
pudding yeah light your life right a bag
of [ __ ] on fire at their front door
yes that yes that's my advice
Gracie Reese I've got a friend who is
such a creep we always break [ __ ] and
there's a real liability so I don't want
that buyer in my party how can I do it
without hurting his feelings I'm afraid
you're gonna break my spell you're kind
of crazy maybe Tikas an exorcism we
become weak chill out so greasy Reese
just be honest with your friends tell
them maybe I should take a chill pill
yeah all right
ribbon ribbon vapes I keep throwing
parties but there was crap hardly anyone
shows up what's your secret to throwing
a memorable party and getting people to
come just put a lot of free yellow shot
a lot of cops people like people like
party things if you smoke weed but I
also put out lots of weed for people
like hors d'oeuvres of wing orders a
weave edible yeah Makemake weed food to
put that out that's a really good way
I've done it
it works fantastically all that advice
and if you can't throw a good party
after that like me a bad person
yeah Andrew Magoo asks the woman across
the road for me always changes with the
windows open do I talk with each other
the whole streak in Sierre just keep
watching you shouldn't be watching in
the first place but I would not tell her
but don't tell her yes just don't tell
her yeah but just don't look either door
that's weird
this is man life advice with seth rogen
listen to us yeah cuz we're sino we're
actors
yes actors really know what they're
talking about yeah we are sitting with
fake people we make some noises yep